a former Marine is in police custody
this morning after a nearly three hours
standoff at Orlando International
Airport officers arrested Michael
Pettigrew after they said he pointed a
fake gun inside the rental car terminal
and asked police to shoot him Omar
Villafranca is at Orlando International
Airport with how officers have got the
26 year-old to surrender Omar
good morning good morning this is the
area where police and SWAT teams
converge right here by the rental car
area inside the terminal now Pettigrew
was captured without a shot being fired
but he now faces an aggravated assault
charge and police say it could have been
much worse this amateur video captured
from inside Orlando International
airport's rental car terminal
appears to show police negotiating with
a suspected gunman
I saw people started running around
dropping suitcases but then I saw the
guy right there and I just kind of froze
I didn't know what to do that guy had
the gun to his head the crisis ended
without any shots being fired and with
officers arresting 26 year old Michael
Pettigrew our negotiators did a
phenomenal job talking with the subject
for about two hours
and finally got him to peacefully
surrender
he's been committed under the Baker Act
for a mental evaluation police recovered
this gun at the scene but it turned out
to be a fake he did point the gun at the
officers that's why there are pending
charges on him and he also pointed the
gun at himself was making several
statements that he want the officers to
shoot him so we knew he was in some type
of mental crisis hundreds of police
officers from Central Florida responded
leaving at least one of the terminals
and roads into the airport shut down
there's a lot more and more police
homeland security SWAT team and whooping
he's incapacitated now
or in custody airport operations are
back to normal this morning the good
news is no one was hurt during that
incident Norah that is good news thank
you so much Omar